comme l'an dernier la question
sécuritaire risque d'être une
préoccupation majeure en europe
encore une fois en 2017 en clair on
s'attend malheureusement encore à
d'autres attentats
pourquoi la raison est simple et
s'explique par la présence de quatre à
cinq mille djihadistes européens
déployés dans les rangs de groupes armés
comme le groupe a remis en état
islamique en irak et en syrie et au fur
et à mesure que l'étau se resserre
autour de ces groupes armés là bas on
s'attend à ce que ces djihadistes la
veille rentrer dans leur pays d'origine
actuellement c'est une des
préoccupations majeures pour tous les
leaders européens au sein des services
de renseignement tous les clignotants
sont au rouge
d'ailleurs l'ancien premier ministre
français manuel valls disette en
novembre que cette question-là devait
être la préoccupation majeure pour le
resterai pour les prochaines années
pourquoi parce que l'europe se sait
vulnérables ces frontières sont très
poreuse il suffit de rappeler par
exemple que annie saint bris le
terroriste du marché de noël à berlin a
pu traverser alors qu'il était l'homme
le plus recherché d'europe après avoir
commis son attente a pu traverser quatre
frontières il a traversé donc cinq pays
différents avant finalement d'être tué à
milan en italie et donc les services de
renseignement aussi ont du mal
ils le savent a traqué les allées et
venues des uns et des autres dans cette
europe sans frontières
les pays européens savent aussi que leur
arsenal juridique et judiciaire actuel
ne leur permet pas de faire face
efficacement aux retours de ces jeunes
là il faut d'abord prouver bien
évidemment qu'ils ont bien été membres
de groupes armés en irak et en syrie
et ensuite même s'ils sont condamnés et
seront condamnés à 5 10 15 en prison 20
ans ils ressortiront un jour ils ont 20
ans ils en auront 40 à leur sortie et
les programme de déradicalisation
actuels sont encore à leurs
balbutiements
aucun d'entre eux n'est vraiment
efficace pour les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens la tentation est
donc grande essayer de régler le
problème à sa source et à dire
d'empêcher le retour des djihadistes
européens vers leur pays d'origine en
les tuant purement et simplement là où
ils se trouvent
alors on a assisté au cours des
dernières semaines des derniers mois à
une multiplication des frappes de drones
par exemple des drones américains qui
visait nommément des leaders terroristes
des leader djihadiste français
par exemple on sait aussi par là
en recoupant des informations qui a des
commandos des forces spéciales
françaises par exemple qui sont déployés
sur le terrain pour mener des opérations
homicide alors bien évidemment ça
soulève tout un tas de questions
éthiques pour ne pas dire légal aussi
mais c'est aujourd'hui
en réalité le dilemme auquel sont
confrontés les leaders européens en
essayant de protéger leurs populations
contre le terrorisme